(Voice whispers) Mary!
You brought shame on our family.
There's something unnatural... (unclear speaking) Mary: NO!  (unclear speaking)
Jesus: Your family says you grapple with the demon.
Mary: If there's a demon in me it's always been there.
(Jesus takes a deep breath.)  There are no demons here.
Mary of Mandala?
She'll do God's will.
(Mary takes a deep breath.)
Why shouldn't she follow me?
People will judge us.
I always heard you're different from men. You must teach us different things.
(Jesus Laughs.)
Sometimes... it's as if I'm not here at all.
(Crowd excited.) woman: She can see.
Is that what it feels like to be one with God?
No one has ever asked me how it feels.
The women are to afraid to be baptized with the men.
Go to them. Be my hands.
It's not right, that He has raised you up to lead us.
You love my son don't you?
You must prepare yourself like me.
Mary: For what?
To lose Him.
(The crowd crys out.)
Jesus: God's kingdom is not to be bought and sold!
We need to take Him away from here.
What happens now is what God has asked of Him.
Mary, you are my witness.
Mary: I'll be with you, to the end.
We'll never speak again, in His name.
The world will only change as we change.
I will not be silent!
I will be act.